welcome back it has been a while I
missed you guys I've been uh you guys
know I've been all over the country
doing uh interviews this last week uh my
guests today have been very very excited
to have her on she's originally from
Chicago she used to sell copiers she's a
semi-pro volleyball and basketball
player and by the way she's also has one
of the most controversial podcasts on
the entire planet welcome Miss Pearl
here hi Pearl how you doing I'm good how
are you excited to have you on here
we've been talking on Instagram uh and I
was just excited I thought I was gonna
have to come out to London I will at
some point come out there because I love
your I love your studio yeah I think
it's awesome it looks like a lot of fun
but um you decide you came out here to
do some you're doing a US trip how's it
been so far it's been good
yeah so that was
ties those were wild the girl directly
across from you not the one at the far
end but the one next to her uh she's a
Gwen singer she's one of my good friends
oh
she had a deeper voice she has like an
announcer voice you remember no she had
a red dress on it no I don't know yeah I
was asking her they were just telling
like they're just saying their body
counts and I was just like this is crazy
isn't it crazy that's not like the girl
was like 200 I'm like 200. What's that
200. the one in the Middle with the
boobs kind of oh okay yeah damn I gotta
go back and listen to that yeah that's
how I was like oh gosh that's a lot
um so so here's the thing I went back
and I watched a couple things so
um I don't agree with everything Matt
Walsh says but I do think that he has
the right to ask what is a woman and
when people say yo that's silly it's
offensive for you to ask that question
that's not silly you can ask that
question and the fact that other people
can't answer it that's actually a pretty
big [__] in the armor you go on Vice
okay Vice has you on you have a panel
where you're with a bunch of feminists
and you asked a simple question you said
how are women oppressed now if I did
some research I could probably come up
with some ways that women were oppressed
but that that the one lady who was
sitting to your left um she's a trans
woman with a short hair the blonde hair
I forgot what what she was but what her
name was yeah but she lie yeah Eli she
said that's just silly and that got me
angry because I was like sitting there
trying to watch this open-minded but
when she said that's just silly I'm like
no pearl can ask that question yeah
because that's that's where the
discussion breaks down right if I ask
you a legitimate question about your
political Viewpoint and your response to
me is that's just silly or we're not
going to answer that that means you're
too insecure to answer the question so
can you talk about like how did you end
up on that panel in the first place and
then what was your what was your whole
um
experience like there oh
um they messaged me like a week or a
week and a half before it happened and
they just said they're looking for women
um to go on a panel about feminism and I
was like sign me up you know
um and yeah they they flew me out to New
York and it was actually like four hour
it's crazy we we went back and forth for
four hours and it was edited down to 45
minutes yeah and that was like the most
loony group of women I have slash men
all right men
um that I have literally met in my life
like they were so hostile towards me
like the whole thing and the thing is
they didn't even keep in like they were
10 Times Crazier in person than on the
video but but it was honestly it was fun
though I enjoy making content so so it
was all all together it was fun to make
but God damn they're mad it definitely
looked fun you know one thing I noticed
I don't know if you saw recently but um
my buddy Justin Waller and Lucario they
were on a thing on Jubilee like last
week yeah and when they went on there it
was the alphas versus the betas and they
were having these I mean they were
yelling at each other a little bit and
at the end you could see there was just
almost like yeah guys let's all go get a
beer together yeah at the end of of your
thing with those ladies there was no
let's go get a beer together no we did
not get a beer together
no they were so angry
um yeah they were really angry yeah
incredible man I recommend everybody go
back and watch it because I remember
watching that and I was like okay this
girl is gonna have I what I what I
expected was like rational points from
both sides and I didn't get that at all
and I kept like waiting for somebody to
come up with some kind of Statistics to
like back up what they were saying and
then when they told you you were Silly
for asking the question I was like this
is this is like there's no debate here
like you the other people who are
against you are not qualified to have
this discussion there are people
qualified to have a discussion about
feminism there are even if I don't agree
with them they're qualified because
they're educated in it what I was
watching was not that at all that's what
that's the part that I thought was a
little bit disappointing well and the
freaking the worst part of that was when
I was talking about playing sports
because that's not I care a lot about
women's sports like that's something
like that was really important to me
growing up and I feel like it kept me
out of like a lot of I don't know like
like a trouble I guess because I was so
busy in sports
um and I think it's really sad to see
like the end of women's sports like to
me like when you let men into women's
sports that's the end of it yeah like
that like women's sports isn't women's
sports and when I asked when I was
expressing this on the panel they told
me to try they're like because I was
saying
I can't bench what a guy benches I can't
I can't do the same things a guy does
like I'm six foot I'm not I'm top 15
percent of height for men like half a
percent of height for women and the the
Eli dude was like have you tried
confidence I was like what that's what
you said it was so crazy watching that
because yeah that's what you said before
so for us in Texas we had this um boy
that transitioned to become a woman
named mcberg and uh she won the state
championship and put some girls in the
hospital on the way there wow and when I
was listening to again that the the
woman to your left she her saying
there's only been a few national
championships that have been won by
trans men in women's sports and I'm like
well 0.02 percent of the population of
trains so that's the reason why again
the problem is this like that is not an
excuse this idea that just because it's
happened a few times doesn't I have no
problem with somebody being trans what I
have a problem with is when my daughter
wants to do female wrestling in in Texas
and then she's in there and she has to
go up against a man who oh let's say a
trans person who went through male
puberty well and I just don't think
anyone understands like how hard we work
for those like few moments like we work
so hard like I started playing
volleyball when I was in fifth grade I
started playing basketball maybe like
second or third like I I've been playing
for over 10 years and I can count on one
hand the moments like I've had to go for
a State title or for
um an NCAA like I went to the ncaas
twice in volleyball in volleyball
Mountain a lot to me you know to go to
that and then I went to State uh one
once so you know I had three moments and
like 15 you know about 15 I don't know
16 roughly years yeah and it's like so
these girls like and that happened at
Riley Gaines girl she trained for 15
freaking years maybe even more and her
whole entire career leads up to this one
moment that's supposed to be her moment
and you put a dude in that like now I've
never played against a dude well other
than in like pick up basketball I've
done that but but you know
professionally but I could just imagine
like going to all of that work and and
we worked so hard that's the thing like
we get there's no money at the end of it
there's nothing at the end of it except
for like a very very small percentage so
we work so hard for the the little
opportunity that there is and we all do
it because we love it and they're
they're trying to give that to dudes
like I just I just have an issue with
that so you played division one where no
I didn't play division okay I wish you
know no I played um division three I
played basketball volleyball and I ran
track where was this I'm Elmhurst
College is this in Illinois yeah it's a
very small School in Illinois I played
for Ohio Northern for a year and then I
transferred okay uh so I'm a basketball
Junkie okay describe I've never heard
you talk about this describes Pearl's
basketball game
um I'm very I'm very aggressive in the
pain I was really good rebounder so like
are you usually the tallest person even
in division three or on your team are
you the second tallest person on your
team division three I'm one of the top
in division one like that's the thing I
was actually short
um for the positions I was division for
division one you play the three maybe
the two but you can't play the four no
you can't those girls are six eight
correct yeah yeah so um and same with
volleyball too
um like for my position you kind of had
to be like six two I don't know that
much about uh six player volleyball
right the hardwood fall yeah yeah are
there a lot of different are the heights
all different or the girls all around
the same no the heights are all
different
um I was a middle slash like outside but
those are a bit taller back rows shorter
okay I didn't realize that I had no idea
about that though yeah the little bear
the one in the other color jersey
they're like the shortest one usually so
in when you play college basketball you
played the five yes okay so describe
your game you're a rebounder like what
what kind of I was I was a rebounder I
was really good at boxing out like when
I would box people out for rebounds I
would knock them over sometimes and I
would um I was a really good posting up
um yeah and I actually had a decent
three too okay so Pearl's go-to move
you're playing somebody who's like maybe
even bigger than you what's your go-to
movie when you were in the post back
them up into the basket and just do a
layup like that was my
you shot you you're a good three-point
shooter yeah you handle the ball not
really I actually want to play
basketball with you yeah I'm so down
um no I wasn't that was my weakness was
I couldn't really dribble yeah so I
could I could do a three like I could
run out and shoot it yeah but other than
that like I wasn't gonna drive really
much
um I was just like a post or slash three
but I had to run out defensively you
were under the basket all the time yeah
I was I was a pretty good Defender
um yeah it was a pretty good defender in
England you said you were playing
Semi-Pro volleyball and semi-pro
basketball yeah well I I played for the
school so I think it's Tech technically
something else I played for the school
of volleyball and basketball I did
Semi-Pro volleyball in England yeah so I
mean are you playing for a team there
like how does that work yeah it's a bit
confusing
um but basically you do your master's
program so you you get your master's
degree and you get like a scholarship
for it and then you play for the school
and then you also play for the semi-pro
team you can actually play pro
basketball in England but I was not that
was like the best team in Europe where I
lived I was not going to make that too
but I was I was a better volleyball
player than basketball okay very yeah
very cool now the the transition because
here's the thing you're doing a show
when you talk about male female
relationships right and I'm curious
first off how did you being an athlete
affect your ability to be in a
relationship and then number two you we
talk about you had you were on with
jediabila right yeah Jedediah had this
discussion before so that I did not have
a baby until she was 40. wow okay she so
she did it and she doesn't recommend
other people do that right maybe I think
38 she got married she's 44 now she has
a four year as many of you know I was
just banned on
on talk and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible